[Música]
o local que aguenta mais um vídeo e um
estágio muito que o niva letras das
músicas de uma terceira que ligeiramente
maior com os boletos dos lados e usa
mais uma impressora 3d sem muito vocês
já vão reclamar agora sei que não tem
história normal quanto mais uma vitória
três meses mas mistura de execução visto
muito barato você comprar uma impressora
que trabalha muito bem por 158 era e não
pensavam há 23 anos atrás ninguém
entendeu histórias por menos de 40 no
translado a hegemonia dos 50 equipe
espetacular futebol o mesmo do 3d que
deus 3d que vocês vão ver em que nível
for o pai de yumi então quiser ter
sucesso e russell enviar uma mensagem
para minha página do facebook da
charlotte uma limpa eu vou enviar um
cheque
[Música]
o sensor outro funcionário é que dela
que não funcionaram
o problema é que pelo menos naquela
noite e que acontece porque a história
tem maior orientada que vai virar para
entrar o flamengo promete como os 85 da
última mente aquela roda que gira é que
eu vou procurar muito senso entre
prudente e desta forma não consegue ter
30 com o flamengo agora vou abrir nesta
rodada por fora limpar e voltar a pôr
tudo no sítio
[Música]
isto é só o empresta vai a parte mais
divertida que é dotar a parte de madeira
porque as peças caíram lá todos os
direitos e por exemplo das coisas mais
horríveis não tiverem podem comprar essa
bandeira que entrevistou farias e mais
barata e com ser encontrados facilmente
telmo chisato então ajuda bastante na
parte ter muito lá na bahia e vai todo
escuro eu vou dar um suporte e ajudar a
fazer os mesmos 90 graus mas vocês não
tiverem não tem problema nenhum é só
isto porque pinha mas se não tiver sabia
qual vocês pel
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e provocam do que os 10 vocês tenham
gostado desta vez precisei irmã dela de
para ou mais ou menos 10 metros de
altura e foram 45 graus para mais ou
menos 23 metros
algumas estão em algum projeto com deus
amigo vai poder representar a sociedade
daí poderia ter sido até a próxima